thank you so much for having me this is
so much fun
winnie thank you so much for coming here
really and truly it's been
like not just inspirational talking to
you but just
fun and cool and you're an awesome
person and i'm crazy
for you i already was crazy for you but
now i'm crazy crazy crazy and i'm
well we're equally crazy for each other
then i'm obsessed with this the vibe
the vibe okay perfect i'm there and also
oh i would love to talk about um your
skincare line that you're developing
so it's it's in the works right now it's
something that i've been working on
for years an idea i had years ago
um i i don't know how much i can say
about it
but look out for it in a year it's all
about
sexiness and about protection
i must say that i pretty much would buy
anything you're
selling whether it's a product don't
worry i'm gonna send it to you i want
you to try it first
i i i need your feedback i uh you know
i'm a beauty junkie i am obsessed with
products
exactly i need your feedback i know if
it's worth it i need to know if it's
the new hot thing for next year
i gotta tell you if you've got a hand in
it i bet it's gonna be amazing because
everything you say and do
is and i need to like throw down with
you
let's party and like let's do this
winnie you have beyond exceeded
i would really oh you saying this to me
right now it's gonna make me cry i
swear this is like too much for me i
can't
i love you and i would love to throw
down with you
and party winnie here walk forward and
we can try and hug each other
i go to i go to you
[Applause]
la maybe we can like
dance our way to the commercial yes
exactly
oh winnie i love hanging out with you
thank you so much for coming on the show
oh my god i mean
look at her don't let me get my my
little caribbean in it
don't oh my god yes
oh my god oh my god we'll go to
we'll go to break on that note thank you
oh my god
[Music]